mit diesem parteitag ist die alternative
für deutschland endgültig bei sich
selbst angekommen
unter dem motto recht sein und spaß
dabei und wenn ich mir ansehe dass immer
mehr debatten um die frage gehen
hat jemand eine nähe zum
nationalsozialismus hat hitler hat heute
eine nähe passiert war
das gefälligst bernd hitler aus dem
spiel
oder ist er doch gern ich weiß kann die
neue fdp die neue ard hat offensichtlich
keinen bock mehr sich von rechts zu
distanzieren gibt man zwei beispiele
hier bernard pascal von der afg marzahn
hellersdorf berlin der lobte auf
facebook neulich wie zitat kluge politik
von reinhard heydrich auch bekannt als
schlächter von prag oder jens maier
listenplatz zwei der afc in sachsen also
bald im bundestag wir hatten neulich mal
die extrem ekelhaft these aufgestellt
der massenmörder preise kette aus
verzweiflung über verfehlt asylpolitik
77 junge menschen umgebracht quasi aus
notwehr darf man offensichtlich
ungestraft sagen in dieser afd
alles andere wäre übertriebene
politische korrektheit
wir werden uns als demokraten und
patrioten trotz dessen nicht den mund
verbieten lassen denn die politische
korrektheit gehört auf den müllhaufen
der geschichte politische korrektheit
ist zuviel sprachliche rücksichtnahme
auch minderheiten dilemma völlig recht
meine damen und herren
das wird man in deutschland doch wohl
noch sagen dürfen wird alles weitere ab
sofort spitzenkandidatin der fdp
zusammen mit opa gauland ich werde oft
gefragt ja was wollen sie eigentlich
brot ohne kruste elsass lothringen
zurück keine ahnung was rechtes zufolge
nicht